difference a weekend can make is mike
shield
and the cardinals sweep cincinnati they
started on friday night they were in the
cellar of the division
and you win a few games and all of a
sudden things look a lot different and
it feels different
so the cardinals take the field adam
wainwright is on the mound
four starts this year one quality start
and that was his last timeout against
the nationals and he struck
out ten third time through the lineup he
struck out
seven he was magnificent that night it
was a tough loss for the cardinals they
dropped it late
curveball swung on and missed strikeout
number one for adam wainwright
one away here's rhys hoskins hoskins has
faced wainwright three times two for
three
goldschmidt way off the bag at first
inside corner struck him out
back-to-back case for adam wainwright
and that'll bring up bryce harper the 01
pitch to harper
grounded into the shift de young
and one two three inning mixed in with a
couple of strikeouts
zach wheeler has allowed three or more
runs in all three starts
since seven innings of one hit scoreless
pitching in his debut against the braves
pitched against the giants last monday
took a no decision yeah the one-two
pitch to him
and a fastball called strike three tom
it doesn't appear that people want to
put the ball in play today
i don't know what he's looking for
because it was 98 paint maybe he just
figured
yeah i have no chance carlson with three
homers he's driven in 12
runs for the cardinals so we get a foul
tip back-to-back strikeouts for wheeler
two outs
and if he takes it it's a strike at the
top of the zone inside the lefty right
there
just another perfect placement gold
schmidt batting 241 with two homers
here's the 1-0 swing at a high fly ball
right side
and hoskins calling for it in front of
nick maton he'll make the catch
one two three inning the pitch swing and
a miss
he's out missing a curveball three
strikeouts in a row for wainwright
five in the game goldschmidt popped out
his first time up
got a fly ball out to left center field
it's not deep miller's coming in he
doesn't see it then he looks and makes
the grab i shouldn't say he
doesn't see it i think he wondered if
odouble was coming
so he wanted to make sure that he wasn't
in the neighborhood
but he made the catch it made it more
difficult
at the end because he wasn't sure where
o'double was
he singled his first time up only been
two games where jt
did not reach base safely and those are
two games where he didn't start
came off the bench and lions went into
left center field at bay city's two for
two
here's d.d gregorius pd hit into a 3-6-3
double play his last time up the pitch
swung on and popped up foul over on the
third base side giving it a look aronado
he's got a play he'll make the catch on
the warning track
out beyond the philly's bullpen and dede
gregorius has seen two pitches tonight
he's got a double play and a foul pop-up
here at st louis we move to the bottom
of the fifth inning it'll be aronado
yadier molina and paul deyoung against
zach wheeler who has struck out
six through four swag and a miss
threw a sinker at 97 seven strikeouts
for wheeler
he came in with eight career strikeouts
in two games at busch stadium he has
seven tonight
off the hands out to second maitan
throws out molina 3-2
swung on driven to right and that is
going to fall for a base hit
he stayed with a fastball and paul
deyoung stayed on it first hit comes in
the fifth for st
louis really good at bat right there
clearly that's obvious but what i love
the most is
he battles but he stays within himself
but look at the swing right here this is
99 down and what you're supposed to do
with this you stay inside it
off the end of the bat popped up back at
first
reese in fair territory makes the grab
knitting is over cardinals got their
first hit of the night their first base
shutter
a single by d young we played five gave
up a
single in the second then erased on a
double play
single in the fourth erased on a double
play and a base hit
by rio muto last inning and then
eventually he was
left stranded what struck him out
seven tonight for wainwright stretch
in the pitch the bunt up and in popped
up and it
drops wheeler's got it fires to second
there's one
and a throw on to first it's a double
play how about that
great recognition right there from zach
he noticed that wainwright basically
fell in the batter's box it was adam
he got it let it drop runner had to hold
it first
easy double play each pitcher has faced
just one man over the minimum to this
point
as reese hoskins begins the seventh
inning
and a high fly ball to deep left field
going back as o'neill that one is long
gone
up into big mac lands
solo home run for reese hoskins he got a
hanger and he didn't miss it
it's his fourth home run of this road
trip
literally the only mistake that wayne
wright's made with the curveball
and he hangs it and you know what rhys
did right there
wow that's a bomb yeah it is one ball no
strikes on baum who is struck out and
grounded out
and hits a fly ball into shallow right
williams diving
catch and he comes up with it what a
play
justin williams tremendous catch in
right field there's a fast ball
away and williams got a great jump on it
made the catch hit the deck
right back out there for the eighth
inning he's allowed five hits
it was a hanging breaking ball to reese
hoskins
his seventh home run and that's the
difference in this game
no activity for the phillies in their
bullpen here's a ground ball to tommy
edmond he
flips to first wheeler is out the
cardinals had better get busy
it's getting late we go to the bottom of
the eighth one nothing philadelphia
there's a longest outing of the year so
far with seven innings
when you throw 97 and 99 and can pitch
with it
it just sets up everything else the
young had a ninth pitch at bat
in his last step in flight
lines it to right field harper's there
though one out
[Applause]
three two swinging a miss he struck him
out goes down on a slider that's
strikeout number nine
for zach wieder it's eight scoreless
innings for the right-hander tonight
in saint louis what a performance and
we're going to the ninth philly's
leading at one to nothing
well looks like adam wainwright's gonna
get a chance to complete this game
and a fly ball out to left center field
that's pretty well hit going back is
carlson to the wall did he do it again
he did into the bushes and then back
onto the field rhys hoskins
with another two home run game it's two
nothing phillies
wainwright with an eight strikeout night
six hits allowed
the pitch swinging a high fly ball
driven to right center field
williams is tracking this one the right
fielder makes a two-handed catch
but the phillies added on with hoskins
second home run of the night
so do or die bottom of the ninth coming
up for the cardinals with the phillies
leading
he's walked two that's it he's been
brilliant tonight
all four comes joe girardi struck out
swinging in the first
again in the fourth ground ball slowly
hit to the right side
run scores edmond now in scoring
position it's a 2-1 game
he's never faced nolan aronado in his
career
swung on hit high in the air to left
center field oh doable out toward the
track looking for the wall makes the
catch and the ball game is over
the phillies take game one by a final
score of
two to one hector naris gets the save
with the tying running scoring position
and he makes a winner out of zach
wheeler